thank you for joining us i'm john
langler the appearance was brief clark
county public administrator rob tell us
in court for just a few moments this
morning he's accused of murdering an
investigative reporter at the review
journal 8 news now investigator vanessa
murphy was in the courtroom today
robert tellis will remain in jail for
now he's seen here in the courtroom with
a smile on his face his lawyer is
requesting more time to work on the
murder case while clark county district
attorney steve wolfson says prosecutors
will continue to prepare to argue for a
significant bail at the next hearing
tellis is the clark county public
administrator he's accused of killing
review journal investigative journalist
jeff gearman who exposed problems under
the leadership of telus telus then lost
the democratic primary telus is expected
to be back in court on september 20th
coming up at 4 5 and 6 on 8 news now
we'll have more from court here
reporting in downtown las vegas at the
regional justice center vanessa murphy 8
news now
and tell us his new defense attorney
says he has no comment for right now